um king's speech all right okay i was
surprised that that came out of nowhere
i never i've never heard jerry mentioned
this film ever okay to be fair this is
probably
the most recent film i watched that
really made like a massive impact on me
because like
he's obsessed with the royal family no
it's because aoki's obsessed with
biopics ah so before i met aki i'd never
really cared to watch a lot of like
biopics biopics are like
movies based off real people's lives so
essentially um
and so i watched a shitload of biopics
with arki so like imitation game was
another one i was thinking
about like um good theory of everything
there's another great movie
but i don't know something about king's
speech i mean firstly
i [ __ ] love jeffrey rush yeah he's
like one of my favorite actors
like everything that he had and he's
done such a [ __ ] good job in this
movie as well
and i don't know it's just like it's a
really simple
movie but it's just the acting in this
is just so goddamn believable yeah it's
just so good
i've never actually watched it but i
also um
when i was growing up my best mate for
like my whole childhood had like really
bad stutter
yeah so i always had to order from at
things and everything yeah yeah and uh
yeah i don't know this movie came out
and i think it was a big deal yeah
i mean i think it won best picture at
the oscars yeah it did actually
yeah i mean like i i the reason i knew a
lot about stuttering because again my
best mate had it and you had to go to a
bunch of like uh
therapy and stuff to try and get it
because he was like you know like even
like at like 16 17 18
yeah couldn't like you know order at
places right right
and so i i just got used to doing it
yeah um and then
yeah it's really interesting because i
think in the movie they kind of like
gloss over it but like in real life the
way that you like
get like you can solve it there's like
with so many different methods
yeah my mate had to wear like uh a belt
like a big belt around his chest to make
his breathing different oh wow
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean the movie
actually does go through like all the
actual steps
that oh okay that the king actually had
to go through and stuff like that and
like
i don't know yeah it's really
interesting as well and it's just cool
to think that like
a lot of this stuff actually happened
yeah and
at the end like king george what's his
name i can't remember i don't know
what whatever the king's name was like
actually got over a stutter in real life
as a result of this dude who just you
know solved it
and i don't know it's just like it's
very like because you like meticulously
watched through like every single step
and every failure of the game trying to
get over a starter yeah
it's just like the ending speech is just
really powerful and like really
rewarding being like
[ __ ] yeah dude you nailed that [ __ ] my
man let's go
i mean i've i saw it a while ago and i
just remember it was it was a good movie
um i think this movie got me into
biopics
oh okay yeah okay like after i was like
okay you know what i thinks might be
kind of cool
i'm glad you guys didn't put any like
documentaries or anything i was like we
have to say that for another time oh
yeah
we'll save that from you we'll save that
for another time connor would do like a
[ __ ] 10 bites
i'll bring the 100 by 100 can i say like
a one by one
size